What happened in the Void Century?
What is the Will of D?
What actually is the One Piece?
Five years.
One saga.
It’s hard to believe that One Piece is coming
to a close soon.
Allegedly at least.
With 25 years of publication, it started to
seem like the story would go on forever, but
all good things must come to an end, even
if Oda is being a little bit…optimistic
with his estimates.
However, what’s even harder to believe is
how many questions we still have.
How many mysteries still need solving.
How many people, and places, and events we
still have to see in the story.
In fact, today we have 146 things we need
to see before the end of One Piece.
Let’s start with what many fans think will
be the setting of the next arc.
We still need to see Elbaf, the Land of Giants.
And concerning Elbaf, we still have a few
questions…like Who is Loki, the prince that
Big Mom mentioned on Whole Cake Island who
Lola was engaged to?
Will we meet other Norse Mythology inspired
characters like Thor or Odin?
Well, actually I guess we already met Oden
on Wano.
That might be too many Odens for one story.
In Big Mom’s flashback, we also saw what
appeared to be a massive tree on the island.
Is this the fabled Adam Tree?
We also know that while the giants have a
strong connection to Norse mythology, a certain
red-haired pirate who needs to reunite with
Luffy also has a Viking inspired ship, so
we have to ask: What is Shanks’ connection
to Elbaf?
And before we reach our final destination,
Laugh Tale, we’re still missing one road
poneglyph.
Is it
on Elbaf?
Speaking of Laugh Tale, though, we obviously
have a load of questions about this mysterious
island as well!
The first being…well…where is it?
And what was so outrageously funny that it
ended up with “laugh” in its name?
Why exactly was Roger “too early” in arriving
there?
Elbaf and Laugh Tale are the two islands that
the Straw Hats absolutely, 100% need to visit
before the end of One Piece.
However, there are still loads of other locations
that we’re wondering about.
One place we need to learn a lot about is
God Valley, but we’ll probably only learn
about it through flashbacks.
We probably won’t visit this location on
account that it completely disappeared, which
raises the important questions “what happened
on God Valley?” and “why did it vanish?”
These three One Piece locations are far from
the only places we still have questions about:
Other places we’re still curious about,
but aren’t necessarily likely to get answers
before the end of the series include: Lodestar
Island and the mystery of its importance in
teaching pirates about the poneglyphs; the
fabled Emerald City, a mythic place on par
with Skypiea; and where and what was the thing
that we saw sucking Capone Bege and the Firetank
pirates into the sky?
Also - before we saw Buggy get imprisoned
in Impel Down he was searching for Captain
John’s treasure.
Where and what is that treasure?
Does it have anything to do with his recent
promotion to Yonkou?
Oh also, quick shout out to Vin and Tuvillo,
the 2 subscirbers of the day, both of whom
have helped to increase our bounty by 100
Berries each, once again taking a big step
towards 100M berries and overtaking Trebol.
And it’s not just places we haven’t seen
that we have questions about…what about
questions we have about islands we have been
to!
Questions like:
Why is it always day on Enies Lobby?
How were the gates of justice constructed?
(my vote goes to the unspeakable power of
awakened Blueno)
What were the giant silhouettes we saw in
the Florian Triangle?
Where are they building the bridge on Tequila
Wolf to?
How will Luffy destroy Fishman Island?
What happened during the Reverie on Mariejois?
How was the Red Line created?
What was Zunisha’s punishment that lead
to Zou moving around for centuries?
Why were Wano’s borders closed?
And let’s not forget the ever important
MOON.
You know, sometimes I feel bad for anime only
watchers…because they don’t get to ask
questions like:
Why are there seven moons?
Are the sky islanders from the moon?
What is Eneru doing up there with the space
pirates and army of automatons?
Okay, let me catch my breath.
That’s 31 questions for those of you keeping
score and those are only questions about the
geography of One Piece.
But what about the over 1,000 characters of
One Piece - well, we have plenty of questions
about them, too!
Some important characters exist only in legend
- we haven’t even seen them and yet they
have an impressive presence in the series.
The first that comes to mind is Rocks D. Xebec.
Who is he?
What was his goal?
How did he gather such a powerful crew?
And what was his ultimate fate?
And what about the greatest scientific mind
of the world government - the creator of the
pacifistas and the artificial devil fruits.
Who is Dr. Vegapunk?
On the somewhat less important side, though,
we also have Scopper Gaban.
Where is the Pirate King’s third in command?
Was he Crocus’s mysterious samurai friend?
And finally…who is Charlotte Snack?
There is a whole Sweet Commander that we just
never got to see on Whole Cake Island!
And while we’re super curious about these
mysterious figures who’ve yet to be properly
introduced, we’re also missing some of our
old friends that we just know will play a
role in the story to come.
Some of these we’re bound to hear from very
soon and others we might be waiting a while,
but in the meantime we have to ask:
What happened to Sabo?
What happened to Vivi?
What happened to Moria?
What’s the status of the shichibukai who
were being hunted by the world government
- So where’s Mihawk?
Where’s Boa Hancock?
What about Weevil?
And is Edward Weevil actually Whitebeard’s
son?
You have to admit that the mustache resemblance
is uncanny…
And what about the people he’s pursuing
- where are the remaining division commanders
of the Whitebeard pirates?
What is Crocodile up to in the New World?
And what is the big secret from his past that
Ivankov threatened him with?
Where is Urouge - the member of the Worst
Generation we probably know the least about.
With all of his peers being really fleshed
out, surely he has a role to play in the future
as well.
There are also some loose ends to tie up from
really recent arcs - some other characters
we’d still like to check up on.
How will Charlotte Katakuri factor into the
future of One Piece?
Will he ally with Luffy in the final war?
What happened to the Fishman pirates after
Whole Cake Island - did they survive Big Mom’s
onslaught?
What happened to Big Mom’s children who
came to wano after they were knocked off of
the waterfall…twice?
Oh and speaking of Big Mom…are Big Mom and
Kaidou dead?
In most series this wouldn’t be a question,
given their current status of being submerged
in magma, but this is One Piece we’re talking
about and they might just have the Will of
P on their side.
What about the characters we haven’t seen
in a realllllly long time?
We already mentioned Eneru a little bit when
we talked about the moon, but I’m talking
about even farther back than that - all the
way to East Blue.
Where did Axe-Hand Morgan escape to after
his cover story?
When will Gin finally reunite with the crew?
When will we see the most important character
in the series, Gaimon, again?
(Probably on Laugh Tale, since he is the One
Piece).
And finally, in the character category, we
have plenty of characters who we have seen
at least relatively recently and who are certain
to play important roles in the final saga,
but who still have tons of mystery surrounding
them:
Most recently, we have Buggy.
How did he become a Yonkou?
And in Wano, we still have a lot of questions
about Toki.
Primarily, why did she jump into the future
from the void century in the first place?
What about Bonney and Kuma, who we saw in
the Reverie.
What is their connection?
We know Kuma was a revolutionary, but why
was his epithet “the tyrant” and why did
he agree to Vegapunk’s experimentation?
Since Bonney can manipulate her age, how old
is she really?
Who is she, really?
Speaking of Kuma, what about the enigmatic
leader of the Revolutionaries and Luffy’s
absentee father, Dragon?
Why did he abandon his son?
What is his goal as leader of the Revolutionary
Army?
And…what’s his devil fruit power?
The prevailing theory is that he holds the
wind fruit, but this has yet to be confirmed.
And if Kaidou turned out to be a fish, then
who knows what misdirection Oda may be employing
here.
What about the enemies of the Revolutionary
Army - the World Government?
There’s still a ton of mystery surrounding
this organization, as well.
So before the end of the series we still need
to know: What is the SSG?
Who is the leader of Sword?
Is Tashigi actually connected to Kuina in
some way, or is their resemblance simply a
coincidence?
How about the Admirals - Where in the world
did they conscript Fujitora and Ryukugyu from?
They’re absolute powerhouses that the government
just plucked from nowhere.
The prevailing theory was that Fujitora was
from Wano…but that doesn’t seem likely
anymore.
Will we get the backstory of any admirals?
Did Aokiji actually leave the marines or is
he just spying on Blackbeard?
Who are the Gorosei?
We know virtually nothing about these shadowy
figures at the helm of the world government.
How old are they actually?
Do they have powers or do they serve in a
purely non-combative role?
And then who is Imu, the true ruler of the
World Government?
How old are they?
What powers do they have?
And since we recently learned about the Gorosei’s
special secret friend, Shanks, we need to
ask - Why is he able to just waltz into Mariejois
for a meeting with the Gorosei?
Did he know the importance of the Nika fruit
when he stole it from the World Government?
What are his true intentions or allegiances?
How powerful is Shanks, really?
And, perhaps the most pressing question of
all…is Shanks the father of Makino’s baby?
How about the man who left Shanks with his
trademark scar?
Luffy’s biggest rival for the Pirate King’s
crown: Blackbeard.
Before the end of the series, we still need
to know Marshall D. Teach’s backstory.
What is his connection to Rocks, given that
he named his ship the Saber of Xebec?
Why does he know so much about the world and
what is his goal?
And of course, the most mysterious of all,
why doesn’t he sleep and how can he have
two devil fruit powers?
For those of you keeping track at home that
brings us to 90 mysteries yet to be solved
in the series, but we’re far from done!
All of these people and places still don’t
get to the core mysteries of One Piece - What
is the true history of this world?
We still need to know what happened in the
void century.
What is the true past of the World Government?
And what was the Ancient Kingdom that they
clashed with?
What was the great cleansing that led to the
presumed end of this kingdom?
In Wano, we learned a whole lot about Luffy’s
devil fruit, but for every answer we received,
we had more questions pop up in their place.
Luffy is definitely the next Joyboy, but we
still have to wonder…Who was Joyboy?
And did the giant straw hat in Mariejois belong
to him originally?
We know now that Luffy’s fruit wasn’t
actually the Gomu-Gomu no Mi.
It turned out to secretly be the Hito Hito
no Mi: Model Nika all along - but who or what
is the Sun God Nika?
And speaking of his very special fruit, we
still need a certain Dr. Vegapunk to explain
to us what exactly devil fruits are in the
first place!
What about Luffy’s other special powers
that go beyond his amazing feats of Haki or
Devil Fruit usage.
What is the Will of D and the secret behind
his and so many other characters' mysterious
middle initial?
What is the voice of all things and why can
Luffy hear it?
Thanks to Sukiyaki and Robin’s conversation
in the latest chapter, we also just learned
that the Ancient Weapon Pluton is located
in Wano, paying off a mystery that was introduced
all the way back in Alabasta!
We’ve learned quite a bit about Shirahoshi
AKA Poseidon, but what are the ancient weapons?
What was their purpose?
We know that Pluton is a battleship of some
kind, but who created it?
And while we’re at it, who created the other
mysterious, massive boat, the Noah?
And for as much as we’ve heard about Pluton
and Poseidon, we’ve learned absolutely nothing
about Uranus.
What and where is this final ancient weapon?
And, of course, we’re missing the ultimate
mystery - the treasure Luffy has been searching
for since Chapter 1.
What is the One Piece?
Before our final category, there are some
other miscellaneous things that simply need
to happen before the end of the series.
We need to know what the egg was on the Oro
Jackson!
We need to see the Ope-Ope no Mi’s immortality
surgery come into play.
We need to see the Grand Fleet reappear in
the final war.
And there are a few things that aren’t super
necessary, but we’d really, really, really
like to see them, so get your pen and paper
and start writing those letters to Oda!
A lot of fans would love to see another Davy
Back Fight with higher stakes.
We’d also like to see the Thousand Sunny’s
Klabautermann make an appearance.
And while we are now in the era of God Usopp,
what I wouldn’t do to see Sogeking just
one last time before the end.
People really want to see God Valley, but
I’m partial to Sniper Island.
Hey, if they made it to Skypiea, surely the
Straw Hats can make it…into your heart.
This brings us to a whopping 115 mysteries
we need solved and things we need to see in
the final saga of One Piece.
But there’s one category to go: Things we
still need resolved with the Straw Hat crew
themselves.
We’ve spent 25 years following the adventures
of Luffy and his crew.
Each of the Straw Hats has a dream and we
just know we’ll see them achieve their goals
by the end of One Piece.
For Roronoa Zoro, we still haven’t gotten
an explanation about his missing eye.
We also got some massive hints, but no confirmation
that he has relatives in Wano.
Oda went out of his way to deny that Zoro’s
father was Ushimaru, the Daimyo of Ringo…but
if not Ushimaru, then who?
And now that he’s been wielding Oden’s
black blade, Enma, we’d love to see him
forge a black blade of his own.
Oh, and what was with his standoff with the
Grim Reaper?
Of course, now that he’s presumably conquered
death, he still has an even more formidable
foe to defeat.
Before the end, we need to see Zoro take on
Mihawk and become the greatest swordsman in
the world.
Usopp also has plenty of goals to accomplish.
He has plenty of lies that have yet to come
true.
We’d love to see him leading a force of
8,000 men (preferably giants), become a true
warrior of the sea, and reunite with his father,
Yasopp.
The chef of the crew, Sanji, still owes us
some answers as well.
His explanation is his burning passion and
many theorists think it has something to do
with Lunarian DNA, but we still need a straightforward
explanation of why Sanji can conjure fire.
And for someone so obsessed with romance,
will he ever find love and reunite with Viola
or Pudding?
But more important than his love for women
is his love for cooking, so we need to see
him finally find the sea he’s always dreamed
of: the All Blue.
We don’t have too many questions about Nami,
but given that she was adopted after being
found by Bellemere, we could still ask where
she’s originally from and who her parents
are.
It doesn’t really matter, but given that
we’ve gotten a lot of extra backstory for
Sanji and Zoro and everybody on our crew seems
to secretly have special parents, it could
still happen.
But what absolutely needs to happen is that
Nami needs to achieve her dream of completing
a map of the world!
With Chopper, we have a few questions about
his zoan fruit.
A lot of theorists speculate that his monster
point is a forced awakening, but we could
still use confirmation from Oda.
Also, given that we’ve only ever really
seen him as a human/reindeer hybrid, we have
to ask: Can Chopper go full human?
I don’t want to see it because it would
be uncanny and terrifying, but I have to ask.
By the end of the series, though, our favorite
doctor needs to cure the world’s diseases.
Maybe he won’t get every single one, but
a great one for him to cure would be the laughing
side effects of the Smile fruits, allowing
him to further restore the Country of Wano.
With Robin, most of her big mysteries were
already covered in the section about the True
History, since her dream is to…uncover the
True History.
However, there is a very pressing question…where
is her cowgirl hat?
We can only pray that her signature hat makes
a return in the Final Saga.
In order for us to uncover all that true history,
she also needs to find the remainder of the
poneglyphs and decipher them!
Given that we only just now found out what
the first poneglyph we saw in Alabasta said,
it would be really nice if Oda could give
us some translations of the other poneglyphs
as well.
Franky isn’t too mysterious of a figure
- he kind of lets it all hang out.
Sometimes a little too literally.
But before the end of the series, we’re
sure to see him sail his dream ship, the Thousand
Sunny, around the globe.
Brook, our favorite skeletal musician, obviously
has to reunite with Laboon, but we’d also
like to see how the #1 Bop, Bink’s Sake,
fits in with the One Piece, as has been highly
speculated.
We don’t have too many questions about Jinbei,
but we do want to see him achieve his goal
of brokering peace between Fishmen and humans,
as well as seeing fishmen return to the surface.
We also don’t really have questions about
our new best friend Yamato…at least not
yet.
But we do have some questions about our captain
- Monkey D. Luffy.
Such as…who is his mom and is it Crocodile?
And while we’re at it, who’s his grandma,
because we don’t know who Dragon’s mom
/ Garp’s wife and/or partner was either.
We also need to see him reunite with his mentor
Shanks, as well as return his signature Straw
Hat, in a moment that’s sure to leave fans
the world over in tears.
We also need to find out what the mysterious
dream that he shares with Roger is.
And, last, but certainly not least, we need
to see Luffy become the King of the Pirates.
Oh actually, for Luffy’s mom there is one
extrememly wild theory out there, that you
certainly shouldn’t miss!